okay I've been looking forward to
answering this week's audience questions
let's get right into it first one hey
David should Donald Trump replace Mike
Pence as his running mate for 2020 this
is an easy one the answer is no Pence is
basically invisible he has made himself
transparent even though the only way in
which the Trump administration has been
transparent is that if Mike Pence is in
the room he must be see-through because
he's barely anywhere so if you replace
Pence and run with somebody else you
actually call attention to the fact that
yet again you're losing an important
person and/or you don't want him to be
part of your second term if indeed
you're going to get one it's also from a
strategy perspective hard for me to
imagine who would better serve Donald
Trump in terms of helping him win in the
sense that Pence is from that creepy
religious social conservative wing of
the Republican Party which Donald Trump
needs help with not that he didn't win
it in 2016 but it's one of the areas
where he didn't do as well and Pence is
from that wing of the Republican Party
there's also just some kind of
logistical awkwardness if you have Mike
Pence the vice president at the White
House while Trump is flying around
campaigning with a different vice
presidential candidate the optics are
weird and you sort of have to start to
justify that and in a way Pence barely
existing outside of what will be the
vice presidential debate in the 2020
election is probably a good thing and
something you don't want to call more
attention to by saying I don't want him
running with me and I'm going to pick
someone else
Trump has so many different scandals and
chaos and different things going on that
Mike Pence requiring no attention
whatsoever and getting no attention is
probably a good thing and like stepping
back for a second from the specific
dynamics with Trump like okay Trump has
the problem of just massive turnover
people that have quit people that he's
fired
so there's sort of like an acute need
not to have that in general you don't
dump your vice-president when you're
running for re-election unless they've
really really screwed up or the vice
president genuinely doesn't want to run
and they're saying I I need out I need
you to find somebody else this is not
the type of thing where pence could just
disappear with no blowback there would
be political repercussions it's an
expenditure of political capital and the
other issue would be if you're thinking
that Pence is in some way going to hurt
Trump merely by being there I just
disagree I've seen no evidence of that
Trump seems to have this base that is
sort of locked in we've talked before
about how there are roughly 20% of
voters who would always no matter what
vote for the Republican 20% who would
always no matter what vote for the
Democrat and 60 that may be persuadable
although they tend to vote one way or
the other
that may be wrong there's probably more
partisanship than that math suggests but
with trumpets extra bad I mean Trump
seems to have an immobile base of 35%
that if anything is emboldened every
time Donald Trump does something stupid
or make some kind of gaffe or
geopolitical embarrassment or whatnot so
I just don't think that there's a risk
of someone saying who's otherwise going
to vote for Trump
I will only vote for him if he gets rid
of pence so I can't think of anything
even Steele Manning possible arguments
for replacing pence I just can't think
of any reason it would make sense
wouldn't be a good idea can't imagine
that Donald Trump is going to do it
despite that that time when he was asked
about is pence officially running with
you and he said well we actually haven't
officially discussed it and people
started reading into it
I would not be holding my breath for it
and I don't think that there's really
much to be gained or lost one way or the
other
with Mike Pence staying there the guy's
just invisible